about the olympics
it's not over yet it just has started
here's why i feel like the olympics are
a little different and what i'm bummed
about so every four years
well there's there's a couple things
that happen
that you and i bond heavily over
world cup euro cup winter olympics
summer olympics and it's a time where
you and i really get together and we
so it makes me so happy because we watch
the same things and we get excited over
the same things right
and i just feel as though you haven't
been watching the events with me this
year
except for skateboarding shout out to
marjalyn de dahl who you doubted
she didn't get did she get them but she
got seventh place
dare you no i mean you're gonna you
just can i just ask to ask the the
filipinos let me know i just wanna
right just shoot higher we got a girl we
did it
india she wanted you it was amazing i
cried did i not cry today yeah how much
higher do you want her to shoot
two goals i know but with marjalyn right
you just say
it's unfortunate she got seventh place
it's not unfortunate no i'll tell you
why it is unfortunate because i know her
skill level
yeah and she could win the whole thing
she
did she did didn't she win worlds in
2018 or something yeah she's
that good or asian games yeah you know
any of those
female skaters like rice race allele
yeah um but it it's the japanese that
win
yeah because we're very clinical mommy
jay won and
and you know japanese people especially
they can perform under pressure well the
odds are on their side it's their home
country they get to be with their
friends yeah but even if like
like you two horigomi who won the gold
for um men's
street skating you know he he his
rise in skateboarding in the last four
years he just came out of nowhere
he's won a couple of uh sls you know
street league
you know which is like the
the greatest of all in the world in
terms of contest skateboarders are in
that competition
he just is just came out of nowhere and
now he is
the top right and it's like um
yeah but that's like saying like niger
didn't even meddle like marjolin didn't
meddle niger didn't meddle but
and a huge niger houston fan and if
niger if you're listening you know
i'm sorry but you know
you know your skill level
is far above that you should have gotten
gold
you know and it's like the pressure of
it and i i i get it
i've been in situations where i felt the
pressure and i can't
perform it's hard but that's what's
exciting about the olympics it's
dramatic
well heidel india's which one is that
the
weightlifter yeah she lifted over like i
think 280 pounds
crazy and um what i want to say about
her is that
while it seems like wow she won the
first gold for the philippines the
philippines
does not never won a gold before that
never first one
uh the last time we won a medal was her
in rio olympic she got a she got a
silver and then before that was
what i remember was oniok velasco which
was he was a boxer and he won a silver
and he got robbed he should have won
gold
um but we have two boxers that could
potentially meddle now
and one gymnast who could medal i know
that the country is a third world
country but
it's like you're never gonna have like
it's teeming with talent so much
excellence and athleticism there so much
everything there
then it's like you kind of that's why a
lot of these swimmers or even like
someone like me you end up in america
because you just hope that you you have
the facilities here
to help you get there so what i'm saying
is she wasn't
up against the odds she was up against
impossibilities and she still won the
goal even you're homeless are talented
oh that's so mean no it's not me that's
a good what does that mean
all homeless are talented
so like when she let me say so if she to
me
what's her name um haida linda heidelnen
just kind of call her heidi i just
called her diaz
yeah i just call her heidi you can say
hi to lynn i can't i don't want to
i refuse
[Laughter]
um she won the first gold right of ever
ever right ever and so if i'm a country
like if i'm duterte right and i see
even if it was like the special olympics
and they got a gold i would
i would like build a little statue of
them yeah but now
they'll do it but previous to this what
i'm saying is like do you think they
will
probably now but what i'm saying is like
they weren't there for her when she
needed the support and this is a highly
misogynistic country
but can i just argue this what let's
talk about you already
no this is not this isn't a funny thing
that's not an absurd thing
but do you think that her struggles
of not getting funding and all the
things that she went through
to get there i believe that helped her
win the gold i also believe i think that
if she had the best facilities the
greatest coaches all the funding in the
world
living in you know a really posh you
know i mean
apartment high-rise you know having a
driver all that stuff
i think all that stuff you know i mean
would be a negative
i think that her struggles is what made
her
get the goal i'm so tired of that
narrative that like you have
why is it everything that i say you just
say the other thing
like you don't need to live a
traumatized pained existence
to get to a good place in your life like
michael phelps
grew up in a nice suburban home
with supportive family with a pool to
swim in every day
not worried about education [ __ ] it
probably goes to the mall with his
friends not worried about whether he's
gonna have a meal on his table
okay how many goals is michael phelps
seven he beat mark spitz's record
probably eight
uh i will argue and let me argue this i
think he did have a struggled life
he would have won 12. you're saying he
actually did he actually didn't reach
this point he didn't reach his potential
so so dumb no not but that's my argument
don't get angry why are you so angry why
do you get angry when you
when i when you look at me i'm just
trying to i'm just trying to
have a conversation with you i'm just so
proud of heideling i ended too i cried
when that happened
i know but how come right how come you
agree with me and we have this really
beautiful moment of crying over heidelin
when the cameras are off but when the
cameras are on you have to say
that you have to always go and
antagonize
what's her name because because why do
you do that i'll tell you why
i do it um i thought it was obvious to
everyone in the room but um
i do it because it's entertaining
if i if i just said okay let's rewind
now
we've never talked about heidelin
let's start from that let's be positive
go ahead okay